bonjour à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nous ce matin sur arte france
comment vous avez accueilli cette mesure
annoncée par sébastien lecornu
écoutez cette mesure mais on lui ni les
frontières des limites de 10 statut
particulier de la polynésie ce tu dis
statut d'autonomie puisque sur les
décisions aussi importantes que celles
là c'est bien paris qui a la main et
c'est bien l'état qui décide de fermer
nos frontières c'est à dire sébastien
lecornu et vous il vous a consulté vous
en avez vous il ya eu des discussions
des consultations pas il ya eu très peu
de consultation
c'est une décision imposée par paris de
toute façon l'exécutif local pas
vraiment le choix sinon que d'accepter
ce que paris a décidé alors l'impact de
cette fermeture des frontières pour la
polynésie française qu craignez vous
écoutez en fin d'après midi alors que
les mesures ont été annoncées ce matin
vous avez déjà cinq des plus grands
hôtels de polynésie qui ont annoncé
qu'ils fermaient leurs portes jusqu'au
mois d'avril
donc vous voyez l'impact il est immédiat
ces grands hôtels ne peuvent pas tourner
en deçà d'un certain taux de remplissage
et avec la fermeture des frontières et
bien c c'est un flux touristiques qui
s'arrête et donc ils vont forcément être
en deçà de cette maison plissage
fermeture des frontières à effective
aujourd'hui et les conséquences pour
aller
la population les conséquences vont être
graves sont déjà pénible parce que vous
savez qu'il ya moins de touristes depuis
à la pandémie
il y avait une légère reprise ici avec
des mesures un peu spécifique mis en
place un test avant le départ un test
quatre jours après l'arrivée ici qui
nous permettait on va dire de de tracer
les éventuels qu'on les éventuels
touristes contaminés on en a eu très peu
pendant les derniers mois
et là c'est 25% de l'activité économique
qui va être mise à mal
il y va on va essayer de compenser avec
du tourisme intérieur mais cela n'est
pas suffisant alors la situation
sanitaire sur place il semble que les
choses s'amélioraient quelle est cette
situation sanitaire
la situation sanitaire vous savez c'est
toujours des courbes en cloche tant qu
effectivement on est dans une phase où
le nombre de nouveaux cas par jour
commence à ralentir
on a eu quand même 100 points de croix a
baissé depuis
ce qu'on a appelé la deuxième vague et
ce n'est pas à négliger mais
effectivement ça commençait à se
stabiliser
aujourd'hui on a pas de cas déclarés de
nouveaux variants et je crois que c'est
ça qui a motivé la décision de l'état
puisqu'il s'agit d'empêcher que ces
nouveaux variants d'invivo polynésie
enfin ça c'est plutôt une bonne chose d'
empêcher justement la propagation des
nouveaux variants lancer effectivement
certainement une bonne chose maintenant
on aurait pu imaginer d'autres le
dispositif puisque on a les moyens de
détecter ces deux vouvrillon comme la
souche initiale des provident on aurait
pu imaginer des dispositifs de tests au
départ de test à à à l'arrivée peut-être
plus resserré que ce qu'on a aujourd'hui
avec un suivi plus pointues des
touristes qui viennent donc de
l'étranger mais cette fermeture totale
des frontières
surtout quand on n'a pas de visibilité
sur combien de temps ça va durer
le président de l'exécutif local a émis
le souhait que ça ne dure que trois mois
mais au final ce sera encore une fois
par les idées 6-1 alors ministre des
autres maire a précisé que les aides
déjà accordés seraient maintenus et
renforcés pour les secteurs les plus en
difficulté quel bilan vous faites et
qu'attendez-vous tracé à man et à
écouter dans la mesure où paris décident
les chemins il faut que paris paye c'est
pour nous c'est aussi simple que ça la
majorité des aides ont été accordées
aujourd'hui ne sont pas réellement des
aides mais des prix il faudra rembourser
un jour ou l'autre nous disons
aujourd'hui c'est près ne suffisent pas
et ici on veut exprimer réellement la
solidarité nationale le point de départ
étant une décision de l'état
il faut que l'état renforce son
dispositif d'aidé pour défriser juste
pour terminer le quoi qu'il en coûte
mise en avant en métropole est ce que
c'est le cas en polynésie française
c'est c'est toujours un peu difficile de
comparer la vis la situation en
métropole et la situation en polynésie
française
la l'étendue du territoire est énorme
savez la poésie française c'est grand
comme l'europe occidentale donc c'est
une variété de l'archipel édiles qui
sont disséminés sur une surface et non
avec une population par contre très
réduite de 175 mille habitants donc les
fondamentaux ne sont pas levées merci
beaucoup à vous mais thaï pro assad
après que vous êtes député gauche
démocrate et républicaine de la
troisième circonscription de la
polynésie